you okay
you all right hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome back to Five
Nights at Freddy's security breach we
are uh in the pits of Despair because we
didn't get to go the way we wanted to go
even though I went this way first so it
seems like it's the way that I wanted to
go but we'll I'm loading pizza again I'm
done Pizza thank you either way we're
going up these mysterious stairs because
Gregory seems to be uh definitely real
100 real and absolutely there and also
my friend all these things are true and
I can definitely put my uh faith in
those things forever
why are you glowing
hmm
softly convenient to block that
hello hi
where am I
what is that
oh are those cupcakes
or maybe yum I don't know if they're
supposed to look like that but I'm just
guessing that they're operating
that's new
you
why won't you look at me
weird
that's very weird
what is that about
[Music]
hold on a second hey what is going on
pal
you all right what's up with you
are you okay
oh
there is nothing to be scared of
these things are the real plot in this
whole game I know that
okay wow
all right good I took care of that that
was a very special one and now it's dead
you didn't have to do this to these
power chargers I know they were
inconvenient but goodness gracious that
is
unpleasant hey I know that Arrow I use
that arrow for thumbnails all the time
huh
but also what was this big machine over
here and I'm I'm sure it works maybe
this is the Poop Machine I don't know
all right
nice
oh good yeah this is good what is it
also who's making this stuff
where are they built what are you for
you are the Poop Machine why why would
you just make poop
where's the point of you you're gonna
incinerator you burn poop
oh
all right whatever
it must be like the trash incinerator
that that's what it must be the only
thing you know like this at least this
room has a reason for being filled with
trash if that is the reason
but my goodness
bam
like I said for babies but I got another
uh trash incinerator going so that's
good
well that looks warm and inviting I'll
go over there then
ah this is where all the yellow pink
comes from
okay good
one more I guess
I'm not 100 sure why I'm doing this
Gregory didn't tell me to do this no one
told me to do this actually it was just
kind of secreted away in some back
corner of the area
I'm the best okay good oh I'm why
well uh he's coming he's go I don't know
what that was about but uh is Stephen
gonna come over here is that gonna be a
problem wait where's that lead
do I go up here is this why the paint
was spilled here
awfully an elaborate place to just turn
on conveyor belts
oh this is good oh yeah oh okay
okay
oh
oh good oh great
EF still looks just as bad in AR
en't fantastic
uh-huh
oh
uh
don't look up to your lap
I'm kicked out
I've got rid of that rabbit
rabbit what happened
ah it makes perfect sense by the way the
veins are Back That device down there is
an AR inhibitor you will be unable to
access the vanity Network until it is
deactivated uh
uh okay sure
what is that cupcake
I love the cupcake with eyes that's
great
okay well good
um so do I go down there
no uh do I eat my way out nope uh do I
go ah
nice
okay good
I see are these real are these like I
mean not like AR real are they actually
supposed to be eated
[Applause]
[Music]
it's probably fine
how is that a thing
what purpose does that machine have
what would be the point of a giant
cupcake with a slapper
that's cutesy
I don't understand why is everything
huge or am I tiny
oh oh oh you just happened to land into
a charging pod of course you did also
you what in the are you follow me
what wait wait a minute
wait wait a minute
what
do you think I can't see you anyway
the cheek is freaking out way too
standard Behavior
so I think working as intended oh you're
up
uh goodbye
well I'm back to eating garbage okay and
right back to it you know
okay never mind I was gonna criticize
you but never mind something tells me
that's a bad idea so I'm not gonna do
that
oh oh
what is that stuff weird battery acid
yeah
oh never mind good actually that's very
smart of you
what I didn't see oh okay I
you've really gotta warn me because you
put all this ooh shiny so I want to look
at that and I'm not going to look at the
end of the dark hallway
ah fine
yeah that stuff is no good though that
that looks very corrosive
um so what was here a cupcake uh uh
chica
you uh
eating that
all right good good
hi everything's good over here
that's that's uncomfortable uh if I do
if I put the oh yeah that's what I was
ah wait a minute no no wait hold on over
here over here over here okay
yeah
okay that doesn't seem to hurt it
um
are you there all right whatever
moment here
don't mind me don't mind me
running for my life
oh
I thought it was a cutscene why would
you do that not I could actually wait a
minute
oh hi
uh Vogue
um
uh Vogue okay I don't know what's
happening hi
okay
an AR inhibitor huh
sure finally I bet I can use the mask
again do I want to is someone a little
bit addicted to it
oh don't worry you can quit at any time
Hi how are you doing
[Music]
oh oh God okay I forgot that you were
still here okay but you did just reveal
something to me there is a return over
here
for some reason but I don't think I'm
supposed to go there just yet I think I
am supposed to go down here and then
come back maybe I have no idea
lost too many paths already so I don't
exactly know where I'm supposed to go
ah I see
let me get my bearings first
wash your paws I'll try
why don't you want to look at me anymore
why only look at me in AR
what's going on with you
you not like me deactivating all of you
what
that's
that's a terrible foxy mask
oh what is the point of that having that
Nar anyway
where's my reflection
ah it's the trash can of course it is
I don't know why it would be the trash
can but apparently it's the trash can
nope
[Music]
oh are you back out there
why would it be back out there
wolf out there
give it a second
what am I hearing
there's like some kind of an arcade game
out there
huh
what do you mean
is that a goodie
that is a goodie
oh wait a minute hold on go away see
what do you even do what do you even
think you do what do you even try to do
you don't do anything you can't do
anything
you're just a digital artifact
[Music]
oh wow lunch box
I don't know what good a lunchbox is
gonna do in the digital realm but well
bye you're quick
I bet it's this big organic gain it's
not a candy cane and I can't at all
yep
[Music]
The Fanny is that chica who is that
chowder
uh
yep uh-huh
oh man
all right don't bother me
I said don't bother me
okay well this is unfortunate okay well
this is extremely unfortunate uh was
that chica
that better not be chica bursting
through those doors
you know that would have been a really
good opportunity for that to occur yeah
sometimes I just say things in the hopes
that they would actually happen
[Applause]
but no I just got dumbass over here
doesn't know how to operate a push door
oh I'm sorry is it too complicated for
you can you not figure it out
this is sad oh man it would sure be bad
if I approach these doors and then they
open and Chica got me
sure would be
that's baloney
that's ridiculous why do you look away
no unless your head's gone backwards I
don't know
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute how did you
do that
how did you do that
how
where did you come from
well you don't seem like much of a
threat so I guess it's weird all the
animatronics I know they're in complete
disrepair but they really have not been
that much of a threat this entire time
and you'd think
because
The Entity won't be able to track me
down you say well what about
I mean I work for the time being oh
thank you by deactivating the parent
node you ever stored power to the east
side of the mega Pizza Plex
good
if you deactivated all the parent nodes
security nodes in the west you should be
able to reach your friend under the Roxy
Raceway thanks
what
what why does it go on into eternity is
that why my 4090 can't render this is
because the distance is actually into
Infinity
there it is
I don't remember this
oh remember this what is that
what is that
this seems like more than a r
what
why are you back there
oh it's fine just a refreshing sprinkle
and now I this is really making me mad
because I did I missed that one way way
back way back I missed that one and I
know that's going to come back and bite
me in the ass but whatever
it's not like I'm gonna miss out on any
of the secrets but I've been meaning to
deactivate all those in for some reason
I just so happened to miss one I
probably have missed more than one I
know I have but I'm gonna be I'm gonna
act like I've only missed one that helps
to piece my brain a bit better
anyway chica you're really slow
unless this is going to take me a while
over here and then I'm gonna have a
problem
oh man I'm about to have a problem oh
boy
yes oh boy I'm about to have a problem
aren't I Ah that's a problem Ah that's a
problem there's your problem right there
oh it's a problem I got a big old cheek
problem oh boy no okay wait hold on okay
fine
man
you see that would have been really
interesting the dramaticism of me being
cornered by uh
my Chico over here but you could just
decide to go somewhere completely else
and forget that I was over here very
conveniently well that really is sad
see again it would have been a great
opportunity to kill me but you didn't
so whatever
thing
everything again
said it was safe here where where where
did you say I said should be safe it is
not safe and I am not wrong
where
where's oh it's big ah he's real big
okay um oh wow that's so odd
star
lightning
I'm unsure of what is
like
I I appreciate you destroying the
quality of my video but
I uh weird those things are weird
I don't get it I don't know it you the
ghost of Bonnie
is that the problem here
ah thank you
oh I can take off the mask
oh that's convenient
hey wait
hey
I think I slipped into the back rooms
yeah I'm pretty sure I slipped into the
back rooms
and I don't think anyone can argue with
that because that mask was definitely
causing me to no clip all over the place
so not a surprise
oh Barber
yep
something right here
you're just taunting me because those
lights look like those little floor
signs and you know I missed one and you
know I'm peeved about it so why don't
you go to hell
torque and oil torque and toil
diesel
huh
oh never mind I won't then
okay
totally fine
all this is so fine and so good
huh oh
what why
this is illogical this is illogical
the geometry shouldn't just intersect
like this I don't care if it's like a
geological infestation something's not
why
are you doing oh
you're dead anyway
I thought it was a game that I could
play
interesting
okay so I'm in the
ah ah it's the hair salon I do remember
this
what
Roxy
how you doing
who was there
you can't hide from me
[Music]
Gregory
no
no no Gregory are you there
I'm okay
I found a spot to hide
let's turn off the nose in the salon to
follow rocks uh-huh
yeah well that sounds like a you problem
that sounds like uh you need to take
care of that yourself
um so what was that like Roxy was just
like I'm burning up is that in reference
to the fire
because that sounds like it's in
reference to the fire and uh that's
hilarious if it is what the frick
what the heck
okay
oh I can't go that way
so
I guess I just follow
oh hello yeah okay seeing seeing this no
what do you mean wait whoa whoa
[Music]
yeah seeing this guy here I definitely
have missed some and I'll probably have
to go back and do it all over again
which I will
but not today I would never today not
today can't today busy today wouldn't do
it today
I have to go find out where this Gregory
is
my friend
I see
more goop all right
they're all this way
everyone's over there
it's so weird
because I'm just like thinking like
the other animatronics weren't that much
of a threat they were never that present
and they weren't that close to me at any
time
so I'm just like where are they
what's going on ooh the uh this picture
so I'm not right about this picture
oh oh
I can't
is that a problem that's a problem why
is that a problem why are you there what
do you do how do I get away from you
what am I supposed to do about that that
wasn't there before
what go away oh I see I see I see I see
I see ah loser
get out of here oh
I'm fine then fine for me don't mind me
I'm doing just okay
I'll be right over here
there's another inhibitor
huh
okay I kind of lost track of where the
pipes led up nope I was absolutely right
one does go over here
oh
interesting I can't get there either way
well that's a problem
um but it's a problem for later I'm not
gonna deal with it right now because I
got this one to go for or whatever this
is
wow yeah that's great
wait a minute
but that doesn't make any sense
how am I is that supposed to be me
eyeballs really huh oh eyeballs
oh eyeballs oh see I wasn't looking in
the right ah but
it's okay
make sure you go wait a minute wait a
minute
oh inhibitatory
okay I got it don't worry everybody I
got there
I got there
okay so that's two oh
this is broken now
all right whatever you say
oh yeah this is nice uh-huh yeah we're
friends oh yeah we're friends
you're so nice good friend
definitely very real friend oh okay
wait a minute
don't
do it
uh-huh don't do oh crap
all right well I can't take it off is
there any inhibition
okay uh Roxy Roxy I don't see anything
what am I looking at no no no that's not
Roxy Roxy and then Chica the poster
right what will
there it is
okay skizzers
gizzard
scissors I don't know if that's an
anomaly well actually it is an anomaly
it's giant scissors why wouldn't that be
an annoying and eyeballs you sure just
that one
it's kind of a lot of eyeballs there
also that was kind of indicating that
there was another floor sign hey
oh there you are
Hi how are you oh yes I know good to see
you ass and oh yeah
okay I'm guessing I'm supposed to go
this way
I have a funny feeling nope I was wrong
unless I wasn't
Gordon plush baby
discontinued yep reminds me of the one
in the lobby yeah it reminds me of a lot
of things
dad used to collect these I bet I bet hi
another one
okay good all right this way I think
[Music]
I am justified to help is that what you
said
probably not
what
am I looking at
no seriously what am I looking at
because it looks like that looks like
the rocky Roxy statue but is that one
gigantic butt cheek
is that what I'm seeing
what the
that can't be right no it's a helmet
it's a helmet everybody it's a helmet
sorry
I just I swear
from this angle it just looks like it's
just a what anyway sorry I gotta go I
gotta leave I gotta get out of here
what the
hello
hi again
what is I don't understand I don't
understand
these fake toilets
foreign
chica went in here but that's a
Chico
you okay
you all right
oh wait hold on the dangling bag of
trash was horrible to look at that was
mean you didn't need to do that fine I
deserved that though I was trying to
help you I don't know how I could have
but that's what I was trying to do so
you can't blame me for that you can only
wear am I I'm fine where am I I'm fine
deactivate you
you again don't know why but that's what
I'm doing you're not there
where where
that doesn't make any sense I was shut
up shut up no one likes you oh I got all
four here
Wham I'm the best give me a challenge
why am I back in here right I need to
deactivate the parent now
is that a walkie-talkie is that a
regular old radio
what is that doing here that's not a
fast branded fast radio
made by Scott cawthon himself okay I did
the things I don't know why chica was
here and I don't know why Roxy isn't
here none of that really oh
what do you mean
when I die did it not oh I must not have
actually done the last one that's right
I just did a puzzle and then I ran away
like a coward and then the last one was
over here and I didn't get it
why
because I died
I did get it before but it didn't count
it as I got it before all right
what don't don't do it okay that's what
I thought
all right you do
a bit dramatic but okay so what is the
deal with that
why did you choose that to die and also
read the sign you don't actually have
any arms left I don't think okay goodbye
hello
oh yeah I'm sure this is what this is oh
yeah I'm sure this is what this is I'm
sure this is what this is done all right
good I did that
laughs
okay that's fine hi foxy you're here you
know what
we missed you
uh-huh our dad area good isn't this
where I went down into the the depths of
hell
uh-huh
o
yep I'm pretty sure this is where I went
down into the depths of Hell unless it's
not because I don't remember there being
a log flume
who's pissing
yeah there was a mention of log flume
from the foxy plush but I don't even
know what they're talking about
I don't even know where that would be
okay that's not ominous at all that's
totally fine actually I'm sure that door
will open for me
oh it did
I actually was a surprise I don't hear
anything
I hope I'm not too late no no no
Gregory's alive
yeah
yep 100 percent
just depending on your definition of
alive
I'm
I'm betting on the FNAF definition where
everything is uh eternally alive in this
wondrous
metaverse that we have oh
Roxy Raceway
keep up the good work pal
hip up the good work
and I'm done
hi
I'm auntie
Monty oh
guys I wonder where Monty is
I don't mean to laugh because there's a
super menacing and I'm like not a fan I
think water levels are super creepy and
things in the water like super spooky
there's something about the just the
hair sticking up man you were really
sneaky Monty if I didn't know any better
I would have been tricked for sure all
right Monty don't kill me
don't do it
oh I'm so good at jumping
oh wow okay so I can't make it over
there for sure
definitely can't so I gotta go back that
way yup welp
all right so good
oh freak God
I'm sorry I'm not doing it on purpose
I'm just misjudging the distance that I
have on my feet to be able to jump and
it's not going good for me
that's okay oh
oh
I'm sweating
sweating and I'm sorry what am I doing
over here what was the point oh very I
see
actually I don't see what am I doing
over here what what am I doing I don't
even know what
doesn't make any sense I'm just cornered
now
okay here we go
not able to give enough Runway so where
am I go oh
over there Gregory I know I I've yelled
at you before for giving me super
super oh super good hints all the time
yeah why am I not running why why am I
not running
I'm like I'm pressing the Run button
there and I didn't jump
oh there's a plaque
oh
I swear guys I'm not trying this to to
this to be I'm no I'm trying to do this
that's what I'm saying I'm trying but
I'm not trying to fail I'm I'm telling
you that I'm pushing the buttons and I'm
doing what I think it should do but
sometimes I don't run and sometimes it
doesn't work and I don't know
see I run it didn't run I don't know why
it didn't run that time but it didn't
and I don't know why I don't know why it
didn't run that time run it ran so I
missed the jump
I don't know it's not my fault
it's not my fault
oh frick okay well I did that wrong
never mind I did it right because I'm
great
and I'm here now all right
God that was just a tutorial all right I
have okay it runs
I got a you can't count on if I hit
shift and then move forward it doesn't
what
oh
why see I tried to get up okay you gotta
hit Ford and okay never mind
forward run I'm just going for it and I
didn't make it
oh but this one doesn't have well that
was terrible it doesn't matter there's
no hope for it
I don't know I don't know
okay is this a safe it's a safe okay
it's safe
can I reach it from here no of course
not why would I
you know I could
nailed it I'm the best get me out of
here get me out go go no what stop look
I got it
yeah I know
oh boy
it was all fine
it was all fine everything that was
there is fine was fine
oh
it's all good
don't lose my head all right
where am I and what am I doing here
and what is that
are you a hot bot
take a hard hat is that you hat bot
I see the log flume has been out of
commission for a while huh
okey-dokey then no mask
honestly I need to cut back on the mask
it's not good for you
dark
all right
that's weird
yeah it's a little weird
thumbs up buddy
yep you got it pal
good work there friend oh hold on
so um you okay Belle you look tired
all right well you keep it up you're
doing great
where am I
Folk
uh
oh good more poop oh great more poop
good
I don't know this is the most convoluted
way to go to get to wherever I'm going
Gregory I made it to the Raceway are you
okay
probably not hmm
I might be able to get a signal if I
head deeper into the Raceway good plan
best plan actually
don't even think about another one
because you peaked
uh fascinating oh stop turning away from
me see it doesn't make any sense
how do you do that why do you do that
it's because I'm murdering you
am I murdering you
the screams are suggesting that I'm
murdering you but I don't know why
uh info
sleep I know
you know what no absolutely not in fact
I refuse
thanks for the arrow that is helpful all
right do you need assistance do you need
assistance do you need assistance
be quiet
all right
I'm pretty brave
I'm very brave hi oh my god do you need
assistance do you need assistance
do you need assistance
do you all right I guess not okay
goodbye I can't wait to go to the
Raceway
I want to be able to race
oh man I'm gonna Race So Good
can't wait to race
this one seems almost too simple
what hi who what what
who was that
what was that it was there oh
hello hi Roxy
uh I mean I have basically why are you
green
interesting
that is probably
telling
but could you also not be right there I
mean I know you're probably blind yeah
you're
you don't mind if I just use the
computer real quick you don't mind at
all dude you don't mind all right
is there not because I'm hiding
I'm about to hide
can you pass through this door please
can you bastard bastard do it bastard
okay come on Gregory be a little more
believable here
uh goodbye
well that was easy
that basically took care of itself
goodbye
you know I'm almost sad they're not
sticking around
I'm like come on I wanna
at least run away screaming Gregory
never mind I don't I do I do
I found him yet
I'd better find him first
they are plush baby uh-huh what's she
doing here I don't know
why would I know who are you asking me I
don't know anything hello don't mind me
oh okay
hey kid come on out uh-huh
oh wait I'm fine
where is she
over here
and then over here
yeah just do that
all right goodbye am I in trouble
no I'm not in trouble because I don't
know what you do but if I'm okay I have
an actual theory about all this is that
like something Gregory's clearly not
real helpy is clearly pulling the
strings here but I don't know if the
robot is bad
or I don't know if the rabbit is bad the
robot rabbit
and I think it all comes down to Bonnie
making a glorious return and actually
being there for us and then we all will
live happily ever after
hello friend I see you over there yeah
did you blame peek-a-boo over there
are you shy
I swear if I get to the end of the game
here and it says like some statistic
screen and I missed one
I'm gonna be so mad so what am I
supposed to do here uh Roxy Gregory is
over there
I don't know what am I supposed to do
here it might be that I have to lead her
back
and then get around her somewhere in
here yeah maybe I do that okay let's try
it hi Roxy uh come over here
[Music]
Marco Polo
really okay well it was a genius thought
I was incredibly smart to think it but
it wasn't right
[Music]
so
well I wasn't even close
I wasn't even close I don't know what's
wrong with you but I was not nearer you
I get your personal space bubbles a
little bit bigger than most but I I
wasn't even close
oh you're not
there
well I solved that mystery
I guess I'm scared by all
[Applause]